I'm not going to get into
roll
i and if you want to see
and
with it
[Music]
and and other efe
i
yes
pattern
anyone
then why not
m
[Music]
and
well
in 2006 of future promotions located
[  Music]
and this
to this complete
but yes
and apparently the pieces or claimants
ah
[Music]
yes
everything
now
ah
oxidation
they love my house
we are fine
and
[Music]
although this crisis
the men
and others
2  m
andrew goldberg
i
a little
[Music]
says
young
the indices like
and suicidal
walk away ok
and is that
and it
has silva
this union allen
and yes
[Music]
yes
yd
[Music]
my life
and
wow
im
[Music]  ]
it's me
from time to time
[Music]
h
for me
and
for 2
for water
yes
berlin
[Music]
now
mmm
put
o
ah tuesday
well
ah
style
yes
so sad one
more
time
and
no
me
and nothing more
music
the name
or
wow
[Music]
ah it
's something I don't know
what to do
and it's emitted  They did a series
yes
and
[Music]
in these six years
I prefer this
manifesting world list to see it than
filtering after the timple was stripped
pressure from the deserter general white wolf
on duty with people the fire in
lima in the back feeling balances it is
said- austin  when fitting the eps in
flower tennis in 125
not
many
and
yes
[Music]
and you
and programs
[Music]
want you technological center offers
good to be were online startup in
shopping with industry leaders
[Music]
paradigm
di
[Music]
house
in watching the race not
without so many he
already says that later it's because a country
to write
oh
and nothing
goddess and
already
george and frankie bossa
and
oh
goodbye
yes
no
and
oh
well
already him
and
before
then it's worth
marking mystic
and
a  shortly
after
we're done
[Music
] this
existed
dy
[Music]
well
mr
johnny as
before
[Music]
no
but
yes
good
normal
or no it's
not over
and
this week
for u  we
rest
and
yes
just
wow
from
[Music]
no no
or
ah
cool
[Music]
ah
and
yes
yes yes yes
[Music]
yes
bours
[Music]
christie's
rigol
to all player
the whiskey
[Music]
it's not my fault
the pastor insisted
guy
[Music]
ymy
without being lips
words
for the distinguished is both a guy
wow
and alexis
and gold
city style
[Music]
and
why not
and why
us has been a sprite power pulse
fanta most this I am that
serves you
as all of us must decide